throughout all eight of the harry potter
films viewers wondered when ron weasley
the affable jokester played by rupert
grint
and hermione granger the super smart
bookworm played by emma watson would
finally get together
the question was ultimately answered in
the franchise's final installment
harry potter and the deathly hallows
part 2. while their momentous kissing
scene changed from page to screen
it wasn't any less impactful in the
moment but grint and watson felt
differently about the on-set experience
both actors have opened up about just
how weird it was to shoot this pivotal
moment
and they're frequently joined by harry
potter himself played by daniel
radcliffe who also shared a kiss scene
with watson in the films
considering that grint watson and
radcliffe grew up together after joining
the blockbuster franchise while they
were still
incredibly young it makes sense that
grint would feel pretty uncomfortable
about kissing one of his closest friends
at the time
much like ron weasley grint isn't one to
mince words about the entire experience
during a 2016 interview with people
grint opened up about just how weird it
was for him to kiss watson
he said i never looked back at that
scene i've known emma since she was
literally nine years old and we had this
very brother-sister relationship
and it just felt very surreal i have a
memory of her face getting closer and
closer
like oh my god i can't really remember
anything apart from that
but grint wasn't alone in dreading ron
and hermione's huge climactic kiss
watson told movies ireland exactly why
the kiss was so awkward
it's purely the fact that he's like my
brother and we were both totally in the
same boat
i'm sure he will tell you exactly the
same thing it was very strange and very
weird
believe me we both wanted it to be over
equally as much as the other
it's honestly like kissing my brother it
was weird
and watson wasn't crazy about her
kissing scene with radcliffe either
she stated with harry i was half naked
and covered in silver paint
so that was pretty awkward in the end
all three of them got through it as
watson shared
they were both strange situations to be
in but both were complete gentlemen
it's obviously hard to put our personal
history to one side considering we grew
up together
but once you've done it four or five
times it gets quite boring
so it definitely got easier while
radcliffe was a gentleman
apparently watson really went for it
while filming their kiss
radcliffe said in an interview with mtv
news i've just been getting into so much
trouble with emma about this because
apparently i said
in an interview that she was like an
animal i thought it was going to be a
kind of a slow
sensual thing and emma really went for
it as fans know harry and hermione don't
actually
kiss and their entire romantic
entanglement is a vision
produced by an evil magical object known
as a horcrux as a means to torture ron
harry talks asleep have you noticed
no of course not but that didn't change
how weird it was for everybody on set
radcliffe echoed his friend's comments
stating it was kind of weird
it is a bit like kissing your sister i'm
not complaining it was good
it was vigorous for me i wasn't too
freaked out but it's a bigger deal for
emma
i think it generally is a bigger deal
for girls oh no
no i mean she's brilliant and we're
friends
but no as for watson she was apparently
so embarrassed by the scene that she
made grint
who couldn't stop laughing leave the set
while watson told j14 that she was proud
of the kiss between harry and hermione
grint remembers that he was kicked out
of the room when they were there
actually filming that kiss they did
actually want me there to kind of play
off something but i just found that too
funny
emma sent me out because i kept laughing
it just looked really strange
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
harry potter are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]
you